when I was younger I loved the Wizard of
Oz but I always had a different
perspective I never really saw the
Wicked Witch of the West as a villain I
wanted her to win and I actively rooted
for her quest to reclaim the ruby
slippers which were rightly hers
Dorothy is brought to us by what was
obviously Glinda's magic used as a tool
to execute the Wicked Witch of the East
and then Glinda knowingly sets the wrath
of the wicked witch upon Dorothy by
placing the slippers on her feet and
sending Dorothy on a fool's errand when
she knew all along how to operate the
magic slippers so I always thought the
Wicked Witch being murdered after having
her family heritage denied was kind of
crap but that's not the point
the point is in my opinion the Wicked
Witch only looks like a villain because
of the framing of the story when in
truth she's rightfully angry about her
sister's murder and the denial of her
inheritance my whole viewpoint on the
Wicked Witch was in part the inspiration
for Tatia Tatia takes place in a kingdom
called morass the people of morass up
until very recently within the last
couple of hundred years were much more
pagan in their traditions and religion
since the rise of the divinity this has
changed the divinity in part is based on
medieval Christianity but there are also
some significant differences there's no
Holy Trinity
there's no Christ or Jesus figure only
the father which is a divine masculine
figure obviously the divinity has kind
of made the worship of pagan gods taboo
Maratha is also home to a coven of
witches known as the daughters of Hakata
they of course keep the old ways the
coven has also been doing a very
particular thing all of this time when a
person is desperate enough for something
and knows the way they can find the
sisterhood in the forest and request
something of them but eventually the
sisters will require some kind of
payment in return
it could be months decades or even
longer the coven has been in operation
for several hundreds of years but even
they are starting to fill the push of
the divinity as less people pray and
offer to the old ones like the Tawaf a--
who guard their
of Maratha from the outside realms a
delicate balance has been upset the
coven led by mother Silas creates Tatia
mother Silas has her own motivations
wrapped up in all of this which are
later to be revealed
Talia's journey is at the heart of my
story it's about someone who is
struggling against a destiny that's been
laid out for them Tatia is really young
and a bit naive at first but very
intuitive and there are very powerful
forces at work at all times
Tatia begins to discover who she is at a
time in which witchcraft has been
outlawed and disposable by death the
current King Gideon the first commands
an order known as the ash makers led by
Lord ash maker shodhan the purpose of
the ash makers is to essentially stamp
out any remnants of the old world and
spread fear about witchcraft especially
many things have been set in motion
around Tatia and she is the centerpiece
as the story continues she discovers
more of them there is a bit of a Truman
Show element her life might not entirely
be her own the ash maker is a right to
some extent witchcraft can be a danger
the sisters of the coven actually took a
great risk in the creation of Tatia not
fully knowing where it could lead and
there are other powers at play beyond
the barrier which the two off the guard
Baylor and his minions to the filmora
press on the borders from the other
world Talia is a horror story based in
mythology told in graphic novel form
drawn by the amazing Matthew Eldon we
are launching the campaign in June so
that you get notified immediately when
the book is available for order get put
on the mailing list all my links are in
the description
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was midnight and the silk glow of the
half moon caressed the face of Maratha
there was a convergence in the air and
though there had been nights like this
one before there was something
underneath the column shimmering quiet
of this night that tickled the soul like
an image flickering just out of sight
there was something in motion something
big it hid in the dark just beyond the
threshold of conscious perception but
all those under the moon of Maratha from
the paltry estuve animals sleeping
uneasily in their burrows to the
mightiest of lords and barons throughout
the kingdom felted whether they realized
or not who goes there
we have business with the Lord Stefan he
is expecting us the Lord Steff Ron
mentioned nothing of expecting guests
certainly not at this hour I'm afraid we
can't let you in you'll have to turn
back that won't be possible we've come
too far to turn back now
I need sleep but these past few nights
the dreams have returned it had been
many years since he had had these dreams
when he closed his eyes he could see the
magenta fire burning he could even hear
the singing voices of the women echoing
through the forest
my lord why do you disturb me at this
hour
I apologize my lord but there are
visitors visitors at this hour
are you mad I will not be seeing anyone
tonight send them away yes my lord
visitors in the hour of the wolf echoing
a different night a lifetime ago I am
reminded of their dark shapes dancing
through still woods and of that I see
voices whispering softly of a debt to be
repaid wait and these men claim to know
me my lord they aren't men they are
women both of them I am Lord Stefan
ammonius castellan of rim brook vassal
of King Gideon the first what business
do you have with me at this hour we know
who you are Lord Stefan ammonius and we
know that you did not always go by that
name what business do you have with me
it is late and I have matters to attend
to in the morning do you truly not know
why we come though it has been many
hours since the falling of the mother's
spear you have received us in your
castle why is that if you do not know
come I see I have interrupted my rest
without reason I want these women out
trust in your dreams
Lord Steph Ron for there is only truth
in them
what do you know of my dreams in your
dreams sing the voices of my sisters and
so they shall remain unto the patties
fulfilled act enough games
Steph run or is it all Dias years ago
you sought us out in the Black Forest
for more than three decades you have
reaped the benefits of our gift now the
time has come obvious you must grant us
a boon
so within this book are all the secrets
to my Tatia universe my Tatia series
I've got all the concept art in here
I've got the script actually this draft
of the script needs to be updated but
yeah here it is I'm super excited to
show this to you guys and to show you
guys the story and to unleash it upon
everybody like I said you guys can get
put on the mailing list the links are in
the description thank you guys so much
for watching and I'll see you guys later
these my whole view on the Wicked Witch
was in part the inspiration for Tatia
gave it I held the book upside outside
you